[Musique]
bienvenue ravi de vous retrouver c'est
une rentrée à rien pluvieuse pour paris
saclay tv aujourd'hui c'est une émission
spéciale mobilité c'est l'une des
priorités de votre territoire
le pea paris saclay relève le défi en
privilégiant les déplacements
écologiques et alternatifs
il y a le vélo les liaisons douces avec
un maillage toujours plus importants du
territoire le bus
évidemment et cette ligne 18 du métro
qui arrivent la semaine européenne de la
mobilité qui s'est tenue le mois dernier
nous a permis de vous dévoiler les
nouvelles solutions qui vont être
développées sur le territoire
le pea paris saclay paris sur des
innovations comme parking saclay une
application qui permet de mutualiser le
stationnement ou aussi des bornes de
recharge électrique philippe vendent mal
le directeur général de paix à paris
saclay et xavier duval chef de projet
chez mobility by colas sont allés à la
rencontre du grand public lors de cette
semaine européenne de la mobilité et
nous en dise plus
[Musique]
cette semaine de la semaine de
européenne des mobilités donc c'est
l'occasion de mettre en avant une
dimension particulière de la stratégie
de développement durable qu'on a sur le
sur paris ça clair sur ce grand projet
international que l'opéra paris saclay
porte avec des enjeux urbains des enjeux
de densité proximité avec la avec les
transports en commun capacitaires avec
des enjeux énergétiques avec des enjeux
de biodiversité
donc effectivement cette dynamique
globale sur le développement durable qui
tient à coeur de l'ensemble les équipes
de l'opéra il ya la dimension mobilité
et aujourd'hui c'était l'occasion de
mettre en avant un enjeu fort
[Musique]
parkin sacré c'est la première
application mobile digital est connecté
dédiée au stationnement sur parking
saclay elle vous permet de connaître en
temps réel l'ensemble des places de
stationnement disponibles sur le campus
urbain paris saclay avec la possibilité
d'avoir les places en voirie mais
également des places réservables chez
nos partenaires en parking partager il
vous suit vous rendre sur parking saclay
point fr pour accéder à l'application
vous aurez automatiquement accès à toute
l'offre de stationnement temps réel sur
le plateau de saclay puis si vous
souhaitez réserver vous pouvez créer un
compte et ensuite accéder au parking en
réservation à la cahc télécommande
virtuelle qui sera disponible sur
l'application
aujourd'hui on supervise plus 60 50
places sur le quartier de l'école
polytechnique et sur la zone du moulon
nos deux principaux partenaires sont edf
et centrale supélec chez qui vous
trouverez des places de stationnement
disponibles
on voit bien que la notion de
stationnement dans les villes est un
véritable enjeu
sous les immeubles de bureaux les
stationnements sont plaints la journée
vie de la nuit sur les îles de logements
celle inverse assez facilement qu'une
certaine mutualisation permettra
d'optimiser la quantité de parking
construire donc d'optimiser la quantité
de matière de travaux à réaliser et donc
d'optimiser aussi l'impact d'un impact
carbone donc cette dimension de
mutualisation parking saclay est
maintenant opérationnel vous pouvez
obtenir sur sur internet un appel à
l'application et ça vous guidera vous
aidera à vous guider vers des places de
parking libres
nous avons fait un bêta test de cette
exploitation pendant les pendant l'été
on rentre dans une phase opérationnelle
et l'objectif c'est qu'ils aient au
moins 1000 places mutualisée au mois de
juin essais et pendant pendant quatre
ans on va encore continuer pour
optimiser et voir comment ça se
développe
parkin saclay est maintenant disponible
avec cette application vous pouvez
trouver très facilement et surtout très
rapidement une place de parking sur le
campus paris saclay autres solutions
innovantes les bornes de recharge
électrique et là ce sont 80 bornes qui
vont être installés sur tout le
territoire et l'objectif c'est de
respecter la transition énergétique et
de favoriser autopartage nous sommes là
l'occasion de la journée mobilité sur le
site de paix à paris saclay afin de
présenter alors nous de l'autre côté une
borne de recharge que nous installons
sur le site de l'opéra donc bornes qui
fonctionne en autopartage et
que nous avons 80 80 bornes à installer
en fait sur la zone sur cette borne
il ya deux points de charge 22 kg et
avec un câble qui sera attaché qui
aujourd'hui n'est pas présent puisque
l'on est là en démonstration et cette
borne permettra donc de recharger en
fonction de la capacité des véhicules de
recharger plus ou moins rapidement les
bornes alors certains de voitures seront
en autopartage et permettront de
naviguer dans la zone de bornes en
bornes en fonction des usages
aujourd'hui le déploiement est en cours
les premières bornes ont été installées
il ya peu de temps et elle devrait être
accordé dans les semaines qui arrivent
et ce projet est prévu aussi sur
2019-2020 loupé à tarifa clair en tant
qu'aménageur aménage doute le campus
urbain sur la zac de polytechnique et de
palaiseau et il se doit d'accompagner
l'arrivée progressive mais massive
d'usagé et de développer des quartiers
de vie attractif et à ce titre là le
père est également compétent pour
déployer les premiers services de
mobilité partagée entre tous ces acteurs
justement pour faciliter les synergies
et des déplacements sur le campus et
avec une ambition d'excellence
environnementale
le pea paris saclay à bénéficier des
aides à l'investissement dans le cadre
du programme thé au pcv pour la
transition écologique qui a permis
d'investir dans le premier réseau de
bornes de recharge électrique du clac
wyclef est donc ces bornes sont en cours
de déploiement à la fois sur des espaces
publics l'école sur les communes de
palaiseau hors cei vie
mais également sur des espaces privés
d'établissements comme le cea le cnrs
l'université paris sud
[Musique]
mais l'invité vedette de cette semaine
européenne de la mobilité c'était le
vélo votre territoire lui a consacré une
journée spéciale tout a été pensé tout a
été fait pour vous donner envie de
choisir ce mode de transport
il ya même eu une grande bourse aux
vélos une journée organisée par la
communauté d'agglomération et
l'université paris saclay lorraine vice
responsable agriculture et environnement
de la communauté paris saclay et camille
paoletti de l'université nous explique
pourquoi et comment la petite reine va
s'imposer dans notre quotidien
[Applaudissements]
la communauté paris-saclay s'inscrit
dans la semaine européenne de la
mobilité et organise un certain nombre
d'événements à destination du grand
public pour faire se rencontrer à la
fois les les opérateurs de mobilité
transporteurs mais également les
associations est allé à la rencontre du
grand public cette année comme l'année
dernière on a souhaité organiser une
journée particulière autour du vélo et
des mobilités alternatives ont
co-organise avec l'université paris
saclay pour aller en particulier rend
compte du public étudiant mais également
du public des salariés des chercheurs du
campus urbain paris saclay on propose
toute une journée qui permet à la fois
de renseigner rend publique sur les
actions en faveur du vélo
porté par l'agglomération et
l'université pour permettre aux
associations locales
investie sur le vélo de faire parler
d'eux et de rencontrer le public mais
également proposé une vente de vélos
solidaire d'assez grande ampleur puisque
on a à peu près 60 70 vélos mis en vente
par la recyclerie sportives à savoir que
le même événement était organisé ce
matin même également sur le campus de
l'université paris sud avec sollicite
une association d'insertion dans le
domaine du vélo cet après-midi étudiants
salariés et cetera pourront acheter des
vélos de réemploi est également
participé à un atelier d'entretien de
réparation des vélos ils veulent venir
avec leur vélo personnel mais également
gravage bicycode pour lutter contre le
contre le vol le but ici pour
l'université c'est de promouvoir les
déplacements par mode bout donc le vélo
bien sûr et puis aussi les déplacements
piétons vu celle-ci tarde donc ça c'est
un des premiers buts et un second but
c'est vraiment de construire un
événement fédérateur tous ensemble donc
c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui on retrouve
de nombreux partenaires différents à la
fois institutionnelle donc bien sûr la
communauté paris saclay avec qui on
reporte l'événement mais aussi le pea
centrale supélec qui nous accueillent
ici
l'université paris sud qui accueille un
événement similaire dans la vallée et
puis tout un tas de partenaires
associatif donc des associations du
territoire à la fois étudiante avec
notamment un pacte centrale supélec
l'association de développement durable
des étudiants sont respecte mais aussi
des associations comme the mobile avec
project le collectif action création ou
culturels qui viennent ici pour parler
du vélo et il sera organisé ensemble une
grande fête du vélo
voilà pour cette émission 100% mobilité
on passe à notre agenda et il est chargé
en ce mois d'octobre il y en a pour tous
les goûts du sport de la science
les dégustations mais aussi de la
musique on commence avec le week-end du
développement durable c'est les 5 et 6
octobre à saint-aubin beaucoup
d'activité et des dégustations la fête
de la science 2010 9 ça commence aussi
le 5 octobre
mais là vous avez jusqu'au 29 octobre
pour en profiter il ya une cinquantaine
de rendez vous prévue
l'école polytechnique vous donne
d'ailleurs rendez vous le 12 octobre
2010 9 x qui fait sa journée portes
ouvertes le même jour avis aux sportifs
n'ont pas seulement la foulée bougival
sc le 13 octobre 2019
une quatrième édition dans la joie et la
bonne humeur pour une bonne cause
les enfants malades c'est aussi leur
quatrième édition l'université pas et
saclay reprend la route avec sa
camionnette et part à la rencontre de
ceux qui la composent étudiants
chercheurs professeurs welcome road 2019
c'est jusqu'au 15 octobre
pas besoin d'être étudiant pour
participer au climat ton cinquième du
genre c'est du 25 au 26 octobre un
événement lancé par le club mack-kit
france paris toutes les idées toutes les
propositions sont les bienvenues alors
lancez-vous
et enfin on termine en musique avec la
22e édition du festival primeurs de
massy
venez tester de nouvelles aventures
artistiques c'est du 30 octobre au 2
novembre
voilà qui va vous faire patienter
jusqu'à la prochaine émission c'est
terminé pour aujourd'hui à très bientôt
et d'ici là vous pouvez nous suivre sur
tv 78 ou sur eps.fr a très vite
[Musique]